welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down Mack and Deeks bogus
adventure the latest entry is packed
with a lot of cool little callbacks and
easter eggs and throughout this video
we'll be discussing everything you need
to know about episode 7 obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't anything ruined it then I highly
recommend that you turn off now please
drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the video
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns on the show week
by week without further adieu thank you
for clicking this and let's get into our
breakdown ok so last time on shield max
parents were revealed to be chronic
Holmes having learned the real ones died
he went out to get some air and have
some alone time deke rushed out to join
him when all of a sudden a zephyr jumped
through time leaving the pair stuck in
the past the episode opens with deke
being debriefed over what happened to
them
all the way back in 1982 with this being
an 80 century it's very much laced with
synth music sweaters being used as
scarfs and as always the costume and set
Department knock it out the park in
recapturing the hero we join Russell who
gets a message from Sybil aka the
predictor asking for his help
Russell is a robot inventor and this
pretty much sets up the episodes
storyline the 80s inspired title
sequence pops up and I have to say that
from the off I absolutely love this
episode I've seen it getting slightly
mixed reviews as it does sort of feel a
bit fillory and a stopgap at times but
there's a lot going on here jokes wise
which keeps the ball rolling anyway back
with Mack and eek the former seems
really defeated by the way things turned
out and he visits his parents graves now
we did theorize that the past may have
always played out the way that we've
seen it and the agents were actually
just carrying out how things were always
supposed to be in our minds this was the
sort of causal loop in which the chronic
comms always went back and the agents
always stopped them and they weren't
actually changing history this was
exemplified by Souza who was originally
thought to be murdered but as we
discovered the agents just took him with
them however the fact that Mack's
parents died does show that there are
actual
consequences and it is possible to
drastically change things it was a great
shot in the arm for me as I do sort of
feel that things have sort of been going
on the tracks very much in terms of you
know everything's just going very
smoothly so seeing these graves here and
realizing that there were real
consequences really hit home it was a
nice little addition that adds a lot of
tension to the way that things could go
in the future of the series now back
with Russell he builds a communicator
that allows him to speak to Sybil it
turns out that just like project insight
Sybil gave him blueprints that showed
him how to build tech ahead of where
humanity was and she requests that he
builds her some flesh I kind of got a
weird science vibe from this with a nerd
building a woman but it goes beyond that
in the entry and he basically makes the
robot from Rocky fall back with Mack he
goes to work on the model car that he
was going to give to his younger version
as we know Mack is obsessed with
automobiles and throughout the series
this has helped him bond with a lot of
people namely Ghost Rider I think he
wanted to keep his younger self on the
same path as his father likely steered
him towards this due to comments made
last week this doesn't really go
according to plan though and max spirals
into a depression basically sort of
becoming Thor an end game and he sits
about just making model cars and
drinking beer deke visits him several
times over the months and tells him to
come to a bar saying it's urgent
at the bar deke is doing what I would
have done it which is just the plot of
yesterday and I'd be making myself
famous of other people's talent deke
sings Simple Minds don't you which was
of course used in The Breakfast Club and
it's one of the many callbacks to
eighties movies deke has sort of been
using his cover band as well a cover
band and with the rest of the group he's
trying to set these up as agents of
shield there's the two twins the Chang's
and we get an a-team rundown on the rest
of the team which contains Roxy glass a
Russian woman I think is sort of meant
to be a play on Brigitte Nielsen and a
drummer who who doesn't last too long
now basically deke one's Mac to be their
leader and they traveled back to the
lighthouse where we come face-to-face
with the digital Coulson he's take
the look of Max Headroom who was a
popular figure in the 80s people
actually believed that he was artificial
intelligence so Colson taking up his
look here is a nice little callback to
what was simple at times I love the way
that he works throughout the episode and
it's hilarious seeing the set being
wheeled around now in the wake of his
apparent death last week
Coulson has been living life in a TV and
he explains that Sybil managed to escape
- and is likely building new hunters it
turns out that every time there's a
power surge that strange markings appear
and these are likely linked to the
chronic comms the right - as we see
Sybil creating an army and he killed his
Russell in what was yeah very very gory
I don't know what it is but shield seems
to be getting bloodier every entry and I
think this is sort of to be more akin to
the kind of slasher Horrors at the time
as it seems to be referencing things
like Friday the 13th
Deak shows up looking like Tom Cruise in
Top Gun and the group begin to train
this suck but dick gives Mack a silver
shotgun axe which is of course the
character's signature weapon Mack
doesn't want to lead anymore but he's
gonna have to get used to the idea
after the Chronicles descend in the
location now in the robots design I got
a lot of cool 80s imagery mixed together
as it sort of reminded me of Knight
Rider et mixed with the Terminator and
short circuit I'm not even kidding I
think the head that they use is actually
a laser that short circuit used to so
it's nice that all of this is brought
together they also reference the Daleks
by saying exterminate and it's clear
that a lot of thought went into the
design as it's completely packed with
references it's from this point that the
episode turns into sort of man versus
machine as the group face up against
their evil robot enemies there's
references to walk like an Egyptian and
the arm scene from predator rambo also
gets a nod to as max suits up and we
learned that the timestream is still in
the base due to Coulson blowing up the
basement last week
Cybil of course needs this to see the
past so that she can plan how to do
things and the group take Iran we see
one machine treads roll over an
explosive which i think is a nod to
terminator
but things take a turn for the worse
when we learned that the robots can fire
laser beams the group managed to take
them out and deke hilariously calls Mac
Mac daddy which he sadly turns down now
whilst it does seem like they saved the
day a small robot gets away with the
timestream
meaning that Sybil will be able to lead
the chronic comms in the future the
group celebrate a mac and deke head to
his uncle's where his younger self and
brother are now living throughout the
episode we learned that deke had been
keeping an eye on them and now his
younger self still grieves for his
parents he and his brother have become a
lot closer and he's even fixed up his
uncle's car deke convinces Mac to give
his past self the model car finally and
from here we jump to the Zephyr which we
learned they've managed to use to jump
backwards once more they show up to the
lighthouse which is where they reunite
and I'm starting to think why didn't you
go back for Enoch you left the poor guy
in the past with Colton's hard drive
they can give him a new body and
everybody just has a great great time
that is though until we see that pesky
robot arm with the timestream device
making its way slowly across the land it
finally arrives in front of Nathaniel
Malik who it seems must have mastered
his quake powers and it turns out that
he's been communicating with Sybil this
entire time now she says to him I'm
confident we'll make a perfect pair
which is the same thing that she said to
Russel so it is unlikely that he can
trust her he does however possess the
quake powers though so if they do try
and double-cross him I can see him
taking them down I love though that the
Malik's are heavily tied in with the
chronic comms and it was nice to see him
pop back up as he's probably gonna
become one of the big villains for the
second half of the season just like how
his dad was for the first now we will be
talking about the trailer for next week
so if you don't anything ruin it then I
recommend that you turn off now ABC
hilariously posted the promo for this on
Twitter thinking that it was the one for
episode 7 so shout outs if you manage to
spoil it for yourself before they took
it down anyway there's a couple of cool
things that look like they're gonna be
popping up including Coulson's new body
and the return of Jia yang aka Daisy's
mother in case you don't know GA Yin was
an inhuman that could absorb life and
remain young over the decades she gained
a wealth of wisdom and became the leader
of the Inhumans eventually having a
daughter with Calvin Johnson GA Yin was
captured by Hydra and they killed her
and chopped her up but Calvin was able
to reassemble her and thus bring her
back to life the traumatic event changed
him massively and she slowly became
hateful of humanity and eventually
became the leader of the afterlife aka
the Inhumans on earth she started a war
against shield which led to her death
but it looks like things might be
different this time around
I can't wait to see her and Daisy
reunited as they clearly have a lot to
talk about and maybe she will steer her
away from a dock fate we also learned
that the time drive is broken which
could explain why they randomly jumped
and left deacon Mack in the past I guess
time will tell
well that pretty much wraps everything
up and this was another great entry that
I hope you enjoyed our breakdown of
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the seventh episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up if you missed our analysis of
the other episode that make sure you
check it out after this if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and is a
thank you you get access to content
early gonna come chat us after the show
either follow us at heavy spoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this
multi-kill when the MCU and finnicky
saga box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you've a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners can be chosen at
random on the 15th of June and the set
will be shipped out from then whoever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part Cheers
[Music]
you